I see a psychiatrist occasionally he
told me that the business is booming and
I asked him I said what do you think it
is it was a covet he goes covet played a
role he goes but uh it's modern society
he goes it's people are more isolated
they're in their phones for a social
species we're just isolated yes and
people are pills are popping oh yeah it
feels about suicides up depressions up
anxieties up but I have a theory
modernity we we have it so easy that you
need a struggle but you don't see
roofers like having a mental crisis you
know I'm I'm having issues and sometimes
I just don't feel like I connect with
people and I'm triggered you don't see
roofers septic tank guys they don't have
that because they got they got real [__]
going on that's true it's the same with
a spa who goes into a spa it's a white
lady with a small dog and a yoga pant
and a macchiato it's never like a little
Mexican guy who does construction but
who needs to spawn more than that guy
that's a great point I have a point